we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question about the Joe Biden
Democratic presidential nomination take
a listen
hey David Pakman this is Todd from
Pennsylvania question about what's gonna
happen if Joe Biden sweeps the
nomination on the Tuesday night haven't
watched anything it's really early in
the morning of Wednesday and Ryan got
into this but if he does take the
nomination tonight and tomorrow you
forget to the same where do we go from
there yeah so listen this is more of the
Biden dementia stuff so I'm gonna be
careful here we've covered Biden's gaffe
Joe Biden is that there's a bunch of
different things going on
number one Joe Biden has been gaffe
prone for thirty years that's one thing
number two
Joe Biden has a stutter that's the
second thing
number three Joe Biden's close to 80
years old and he certainly has slowed
down as at a mathematical a statistical
level almost anyone who is Joe Biden's
age would be experiencing there are some
bad faith actors including cynics on the
right who have ignored Donald Trump's
obvious cognitive decline over the last
many years who are now just so chaos
talking about Biden dementia I'm going
to keep talking about what's going on
with Joe Biden but people who are
equating with some of the clips Biden
slurred clearly he is completely
demented and has no idea what's going on
around him there are some really bad
faith actors that are now pushing this
there are people on the on the Left
Bernie or Buster's who are pushing it
because they think it'll get Bernie to
be the nominee it won't Bernie lost
there are people on the right who are
pushing it because they want to just
cause chaos they want to very cynically
ignore Donald Trump's obvious cognitive
decline by pointing out to this these
videos of Joe Biden so we're gonna be
covering this seriously I'm not going to
be ignoring it but again people who are
waiting for something like Joe Biden
forgets his name I first of all I think
you're gonna have to wait a while for
that to happen I don't think Joe Biden's
gonna be forgetting his name anytime
soon and
understand the sources of where a lot of
this stuff is is happening you are
seeing both Bernie bros and trumpets
shared the same Biden videos for
different reasons and I think we want to
be very very careful about simply saying
well Joe Biden's demented and that's all
there is to it and there's a lot of good
information about this online which
maybe we'll have time to dig into
tomorrow we have a great bonus show for
you today I am out of time but it is a
good one I hope you'll join me at join
pakman.com on today's bonus show what if
you could read ten books in just one
sitting that's exactly what one of my
favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink East has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink accom
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video